[Music]
cry why do you do this to me
why do you do this to me it's a good
question it's one I always ask when
producers present me with a story that
offers an endless array of sexual
innuendo so it's really not my fault
when I happen to indulge for example a
Subway Subway in Pakistan is now
offering a three incher because
inflation has ravaged their economy and
yeah it's Pakistan not the United States
but I don't care because you know three
inches
Baker do you know what it's like to have
a three incher
oh God how many different ways could I
get in trouble now yes um for answering
this you know I'm gonna go a different
direction I'm going to leave that to uh
to Jim yeah
um but uh This Is Not Unusual right you
travel around the world which which I I
sometimes do and the franchise is the
fast food restaurants that we know here
in the states they often uh you know
adapt to the local uh requirements or
cultures or environments that they're
operating and so you see different types
of food in what would be a normal you
know familiar restaurant
um
the Royal with cheese yeah Amsterdam as
a matter of fact right uh which would be
the Big Mac of course here yes and this
is quite a history lesson you're welcome
we all saw Pulp Fiction he said of
course like that was a thing people knew
actually it's the quarter pounder yep oh
you know you should have just stopped it
yeah you know what uh to answer your
question never mind
um
yeah just let's move on shall we
[Laughter]
Jim that even went worse than I thought
wow I mean uh Mike a three-incher I mean
I mean I appreciate you doubling the
size of my penis
I mean what are you doing a three inch
sub just chop it up on a mirror and
snort it
stop it
I mean if people are having a hard time
financially the economy they want you to
lower the price of the sub so people can
eat a real meal right I mean a three
inch of anything yeah is not good unless
it's girth
well no no no no that's not true it all
makes it hard to sit
that's a that's a good point because if
you dress left
yeah I'm just thinking okay I know
that's the problem
the cat as the only woman on the panel
what say you it's interesting I'm the
only woman on the panel and yet I have
the biggest
[Applause]
[Laughter]
true
No One's Gonna argue that without it
if anyone wants to keep their job in
their life in their career she wins I
mean if this was not a TV show we just
put them right out there on the table
but wait would you do is the fact that
this is a TV show what's stopping you
from doing that
I for one am proud of him to be clear
about that I have standards I'll say for
the record I just fell in love with cat
[Applause]
so Tyrus I don't know same question
I don't know I went in the snow a few
times I noticed some shrinkage
sad it's sad that that's what it's got
to it's coming here but you know you go
out for a meal of food and you get an
hors d'oeuvre that's pretty mean like
yeah and uh that doesn't even look
delicious at all so even if you shrink
that down a three inch sub you're
getting a half a tomato a couple pieces
of lettuce
and just some
um
it's just there's nothing you can't be
that hungry I mean you can't like you
I'd rather you must just go hungry all
that's going to do is give you a memory
of what it was like to have food in your
stomach yeah like yeah that's not enough
you know I think it would be they should
do this in America I think because it's
like stuff is too big except that they
they would just keep charging the same
price then you'll have somebody with 75
three inch subs talking about I'm
cutting back yeah yeah
what we managed to avoid The Squeeze Box
jokes so that's good I don't even know
what that means never mind by saying
that you didn't avoid it
all right you know what we should do I
think this is really wise we should get
the hell out of this segment
yeah so we have another show I think we
should just stay on it all right let's
just be on Sunday well actually I'm
gonna be announcing a new Fox Nation
special all about three inchers uh
yeah I couldn't be on that show
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else